[Musique]
donc
on peut
dans cet espace
on va avoir une machine au coeur de
laquelle on va allumer un petit soleil
pour faire lui tresse récemment ce petit
soleil il va générer de l'énergie
on va récupérer cette énergie pour
produire de l'électricité
donc
dans
vision que j'ai là que je crois la plus
la plus réaliste
c'est qu'il faut attendre aux alentours
des années 2000 60 pour avoir une
première connexion d'une machine
productrices d'énergie de fusion à un
réseau électrique
c'était plutôt au début un affichage
politique avec beaucoup d'espoir
formidable vous avez 35 pays qui
acceptent de s'engager pour plus de 40
ans c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire
lorsque les travaux d'ingénierie ont été
développés à la ce moment là on s'est
rendu compte que la complexité du projet
a nécessité les ressources
supplémentaires
[Musique]